[Music]  i don't like you going up there alone  you know what day it is  [Music]  anyway it's cheaper in therapy and  mountains always listen and never talk  back watch the weather i will hey you  see anyone else up there no  it's just us  [Music]  this storm's too big  i'm not gonna make it  i have to turn back  see you soon [ __ ]  hello  hey  [Applause]  my name's pam and i'm gonna get you out  of here  what's your name  john i'm gonna call you john can you  hear my life  i'm done  damn it john i'm not leaving you  we're not gonna make it  we need to move  come on  i wanna go home  save the tears  if we don't get moving  we're dead  see that down there jon  that's home  let's go home john  [Music]  you